[Music]
Andrew crappie was born in the top camp
outside of tangata well I first started
I was just a boy when teenage boy and I
grew up with stories grow up with
culture grew up with tradition from
there I tried to translate what I heard
or what I would went through or saw
before not just culture but wildlife
animals to the legend submit first I had
to make my work be accepted by cap that
were through cooperatives at that time
and the print shop was running through
coop stores and after a while trying to
work on a different job where I came
back to pretty naked and we formed in
our association here which the artist
from this community met together to form
this dart Center this opened in 1991
this is etching and using copper plate
that is the medium and I want to show
some winter and some wind kind of like a
coasting through there so you could see
a little bit
I tried to capture something are using
copper plate it turned out as I want to
this is a mother in a son image that
this medium I used sink
plate zinc metal and I have to try and
do the same thing with the background
except I wanted at a really old kind of
texture background or in order for the
image
what centers in focuses in on a care for
child and I'm child's love for her
mother so I've got to portray on this
one this is a portrait of me and my wife
Annie she has been by my side she has
been a personal manager for my work as
well outside of the preacher but this
was about and ruin any non showing her
the work I've done previous years and
the image here which I made into a print
it was called as I see a man looking
through a co hole and looking at a seal
coming up at the same time with his
companion the Husky wouldn't hunters
would take on Hunt's and during winter
it turned out pretty well to finish an
art for watching from your mind or
one to work up and seeing the process
come to life that's the most satisfying
moment
[Music]